- This is the very first
cast that I have ever worn.
It was the day I was born.
This is my little knee and this
is all the way to my thigh.
This is how tiny my leg is.
And they put this on me
to straighten my leg.
My name's Marna Michele.
I'm a singer-songwriter
and I have arthrogryposis.
It's a muscle and joint disorder.
I have stiffness in
the joints and weakness
in the muscles, or a lack of muscles.
I can't walk.
I am in a wheelchair
for the rest of my life
and I can't life my arms above my head.
But other than that, I am relatively
capable of doing most things.
I was 12 years old and I entered into
a talent contest and I decided to sing.
I won the talent competition and I decided
this is what I want to do for a living.
And people always ask
me why and it's because
of the fact that when I was on stage
I forgot that I was incapable of walking
or that I couldn't high five someone
because my arms don't go over my head.
I was just on stage singing
a song and people were
enjoying it and singing
along with me and I was like
this is what I want to do
for the rest of my life.
Since sixth grade, I pursued singing.
I was in choir, I would
enter into competitions
outside of school, and then when I hit 16
that was when I started
auditioning for TV shows
like X Factor and American
Idol and The Voice.
The challenges I've come across
are people not believing in me.
People who ask me questions
like what is the wheelchair
going to do for you in this industry?
And my answer is always the same.
The wheelchair will get
me on and off stage.
Your question should be what
is your voice going to do.
There was this one time
that I auditioned for
a singing competition on the television
and I remember going in and I sang my song
and they said to me we like
you, we like your voice,
but we don't like the wheelchair
because it's an eyesore.
And so I'm like sitting there.
I'm not gonna be on your show not cause
I'm not talented, but because
my wheelchair is an eyesore.
That was probably my least
favorite experience I've had.
Because I definitely don't
believe that your talent
should be related to
what's attached to you.
And my wheelchair is
definitely attached to me
but it's not what defines me.
I'm on my way to a performance
that I'm really excited
slash nervous about.
I'm performing an original
that I wrote by myself
and I really love the meaning of it
and I hope that people
love the meaning of it.
And I just love being on stage and singing
and performing and
connecting with an audience
and feeling like I can
do anything in the world.
I'm so excited and I hope it goes well.
The song is all about being
super confident and not
giving up on your hopes and
your dreams and being strong.
And I just really hope that
people in the audience connect
to this song the way that I
connected when I wrote it.
And I just feel like this is
gonna be a pretty cool song.
I'm gonna perform right over there.
I'm so excited.
I want to show that the disabled
community has bunches of talent.
Just because you're different doesn't mean
you can't aspire to be a doctor
or a veterinarian or a lawyer or a dancer.
I'm not saying I can do anything,
cause I really don't believe that.
I can't ever walk.
But the things that I
can do and the things
I believe in myself for doing,
they're definitely gonna happen.
You have to believe in yourself.
♪ Let the stars ♪
♪ Lead you where you are going ♪
♪ Let the light ♪
♪ Keep the monsters at bay ♪
♪ Don't let anyone take away your faith ♪
♪ Don't let anyone
diminish your strength ♪
♪ Bravery is in you ♪
♪ There's power in your truth ♪
♪ Let's fight for all you can do ♪
♪ And don't give up ♪
♪ Look inside your soul
and do all you can do ♪
♪ Can do ♪
♪ Stay true ♪
People with disabilities, we have to
believe in ourselves way
more than anybody else.
Because a lot of people will look at us
and they will say she's
not gonna succeed at that.
A lot of people will watch this
and think she's not gonna go anywhere.
Guess what?
I don't care what they think.
I'm gonna go places because I'm
the one that writes my own story.
♪ Be true ♪